all right hi my name is aja Shu I'm a
rising sophomore Pearson college I'm a
molecular biophysics and biochemistry
major and my favorite part of Yale is
definitely Hillhouse Avenue which you
can actually see behind me
I love Hill House so as a science major
walking uphill house to get to class in
the morning it's just such a beautiful
street it's a really calming place and
it really gets me in the mood to go to
class and learn in my days at yeah my
name is Corinne I'm a senior in Saybrook
College I'm studying psychology here at
Yale and my favorite place at Yale is
the binary library by nakiya's Yale's
rare books and manuscripts library and
it's really one of my favorite places on
campus I love to study in the vine icky
I bring my books in there to do my
reading for class and things like that
the binder key is also a great resource
for the papers and projects that I do
here at Yale the Beinecke he has
hundreds of thousands of rare books
manuscripts and even objects so
basically for any paper or project that
I do here at Yale the Beinecke he has an
original document that I can use for
that paper
hi I'm Gianna kinsman I'm a rising
junior in Ezra Stiles college and I
picked Stiles as my favorite place on
campus because it was kind of a
no-brainer over the past two years
Stiles has really become a second home
to me from the opening days of college
when my master of my college ran out and
greeted me by name already - I met some
of my best friends here during the
barbecues and my opening days of my
freshman year and now as an
upperclassman I gather with all my
friends in this courtyard for everything
from chanting our college cheer before
we go and raid the other colleges during
medieval night to getting hyped before
the upperclassmen versus freshman
capture the flag game on old campus and
it's really I just found a second family
here and I feel so blessed to have done
so
so hi my name is Navi
I feel rising junior here at Yale and
I'm studying mechanical engineering and
architecture today I have chosen this
spot because this is my the CID the
Center for engineering innovation and
design it's actually my favorite place
on campus the reason for that is because
this place actually helped me discover
what my passion is and that I want to
study mechanical engineering I was part
of a class called
Innes 118 which helped us to discover
all the different disciplines of
engineering and after that I realized
that making little things like that on
our 3d printers which are right in the
back it's just one very cool aspect of
what mechanical engineering has to offer
so the reason why I like this face is
because as you can see in the back there
are a lot of things happening at the
same time and everyone who comes into
the space she has the same passion for
actually creating new things and kind of
doing something which is normally not
seen on campus hi my name is Ben I'm a
rising junior here in Timothy Dwight and
we're standing in my favorite place on
campus which is the Timothy Dwight
dining hall and this is a place where
students from all over the the college
and all over the university come
together to eat it's one of the 14
dining halls here on campus
I think this dining hall has so much
importance to me because of the meals
that I've had here in the dining hall
with my friends and my peers sitting at
these long tables and learning about
where people come from and their beliefs
and their ideas has really intrigued me
but on the flip side there's also a
million opportunities here at at Yale
whether it's in Timothy Dwight or at the
other residential colleges to eat with
professors and distinguished guests
hi my name is Sydney Gabrielle I am a
rising senior class of 2015 and at
Timothy Dwight college and I'm an
English major but my favorite spot on
campus is cross campus it's right at the
center of campus right at the heart of
things but I think the real reason that
it's my favorite is because it's the
best place to watch the seasons change
I'm originally from Southern California
and when I came to Yale it was the first
time that I saw the leaves change in the
fall and a snowfall in the winter but
when you're on cross campus not only do
you see the seasons change but you see
the students you know walking through
the snow together and playing out on the
grass whether it's frisbee or soccer or
anything else I love to come out here
and sit with my friends or just sit out
here on a bench and do some reading
before I head off to class and I always
know I'll see someone I know walking
across campus no matter what season of
the year it is heading off somewhere
EleFun Yale's campus